er ist gerade mal 19 jahre alt und seit
fünf jahren in deutschland und hat den
deutschen staat bereits über fünf
millionen euro gekostet sein name sei
man n das problem
er geht als terror gefährder und wird
deshalb rund um die uhr von der polizei
überwacht und das seit jahren
die ganze sache mit der polizei nervt
das sagt der 19-jährige ein mann aus
syrien als ihnen ein bildreporter am
montag an der tür seiner asylunterkunft
in sachsen-anhalt anspricht ja die ganze
sache mit der polizei nervt sicher nicht
nur den jungen syrer gewaltig sie hat
den steuerzahler bisher bereits über
fünf millionen euro gekostet
der syrer gilt als potenzieller
terrorist könnte anschläge planen geht
ahlmann n einkaufen folgen ihm vier
zivilpolizisten mit zwei autos kehrt er
in seine unterkunft zurück parken die
beamten neben dem haus auch nachts und
das alles seit dezember 2017 jeden tag
da sind über 95.000 einsatzstunden
wir fragen uns warum bitte ist dieser
mann nicht in haft über dieses thema
möchte ich jetzt sprechen mit christoph
riess mir nun zugeschaltet
cdu-innenexperte und nahmen per de vries
nicht gut nach dem guten tag natürlich
noch am mittag
wir haben es gerade gehört über fünf
millionen euro vom steuerzahler sind
dafür jetzt schon drauf gegangen man
muss ich ganz ehrlich fragen was läuft
da schief
also ich glaube zunächst einmal muss man
sagen die sicherheit unserer bürger in
deutschland darf keine kostenfrage sein
sondern ist es ist die aufgabe eines
starken teams von staates alle
rechtsstaatlichen instrumente zu
ergreifen die notwendig sind um die
sicherheit herzustellen ich glaube das
ist ganz wichtig ja aber gibt es da
nicht eine andere lösung als jemanden
der als gefährder gilt ja vielleicht ein
terrorist in zukunft werden könnte
anders zu behandeln als ihn einfach nur
zu bewachen könnte man ihn nicht dafür
schon in haft nehmen was könnte eine
lösung sein
um eben nicht so viel steuergelder dafür
aufzubringen
ja ich glaube sie sprechen die
alternativen die wir haben
wir haben ja im letzten jahr aus und 32
er dann abgeschoben und die länder dafür
müssen natürlich die voraussetzung
erfüllt sein wir haben andere
möglichkeiten der überwachung das gilt
aber für jeden einzelfall
das problem bei den gefährdern ist ja
dass man sie als person definiert
es ist tatsachen gibt die zur annahme
leiten dass wir eine schwere straftat
vorbereiten können aber sie haben es
eben noch nicht getan deswegen ist die
handhabe in der praxis nicht ganz so
einfach
ich glaube am ende das ist ja auch wenn
nicht und teuer aber keine
sicherheitsbehörde in deutschland möchte
sich den vorwurf gefallen lassen dass es
so ansteigen kommt wo man diese
überwachung nicht gemacht hat wenn man
sie für notwendig befunden
also kurzum es ist teuer aber es ist
wirksam und es ist auch notwendig wie
viele fälle wie diesen von einem mann
gibt es denn in deutschland kann sie das
ungefähr sagen bei wie vielen menschen
wer tatsächlich so viel geld dafür
aufbringen sie sagen es geht natürlich
um unsere sicherheit aber dennoch bei
wie vielen es dass ungefähr der fall
hier also wir haben insgesamt eine
anzahl von gefährdern in deutschland die
rückläufig ist
im letzten jahr rund 880 knapp gefährde
und relevante personen werden in
spitzenzeiten 2017 über 1200 das heißt
es tendenziell eher eine rückläufige
tendenz was auch damit zusammenhängt
dass die konflikte und die kriege in
syrien und irak
zumindest nachgelassen haben im irak am
ende sagen dass sie wieder eingestellt